[Music]
oh
[Music]
episode
yeah so we saved and we were with chris
and that's chris told us about um
mia being mother miranda if i
remember rightly i'm not doing very well
for ammo
which is sad oh and he told us something
about heisenberg
is vulnerable to a certain type of
metal or something or at least oh can i
do something here
maybe not vulnerable it's just he can't
control it metal polymer composite huh
time to fight fire with fire
oh my god
cool
okay so hold to ready the cannon
fire it it can guard as well
and it's got a little machine gun
okay let's do this oh my god
fire the cannon already saw my ammo is
infinite in this thing that's good
hi am i going
you're like a goddamn cockroach
you think you can take me on fine
this will be my warm-up before
no thank you
oh jesus christ
[Music]
oh
baby
oh god get out of there get out of there
get out of here
reloading okay
nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice
nice nice
don't get stuck in the corner again
is
you're a bad boy
freedom
red stuff
oh yourself
no thank you i want my
i will ah [ __ ]
[Music]
no time as a world watch what am i
supposed to be shooting at
here we go
[Music]
will never win against me
[Music]
oh my god my face
[Music]
too bad i'm your only
[Music]
come on get some cover
how am i doing oh that's weird you
thought who was
cutting me like that i'd be getting
red but i'm not i'm alright i'm not too
bad
what
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
not yet
no
what am i doing
boom baby
all right what a way to start the stream
damn
ethan i heard explosions what the hell
happened
i dealt with heisenberg now i'm gonna
find miranda
and get rose back not without me it's
too dangerous
no it's mother miranda she's so
important isn't she she's everything to
me
and mine to me with heisenberg
you've lost your lead what are you going
to do i don't know but i'm saving rose
you'd never know do you
even when i took mia's place in your
home
poor ethan who are you where are you
i love how you don't sell them okay like
okay cool whatever
but
enough
remember evelyn and her power over them
all
rose is her successor no
rose is evelyn's true complete form
she will grow to fully control the
masses
calm yourself rose will be saved
the mega my seat catalogs all of us
however she will be reborn as
my daughter she's my child not yours
why did rose come to be was it because
of her i
knew it was her and you are truly a
special case
but i've learned all i can
your worth as a lab rat has run out
miranda you coward come on and face me
i will make sure to sample your blood
for later
i don't know how he's going to come back
from this one
the ceremony will be complete and i will
become
her true mother bound for eternity
blood
she's bathing in my heart pus
i've waited so long the dreams
really can come true
or not i can't wait to see my true
child again
so all that crap about oh she's just
testing you
so that you can go up the ranks that
wasn't true that was just what
heisenberg thought
captain i've confirmed the death of
ethan winters i wasn't able to retrieve
the body
but i've recorded evidence yeah she did
share your screen
and i'll go over the situation
my team and i were careless yesterday
we took down the transformed miranda but
we didn't kill her
who knew she could fake being a corpse
since miranda could have infected ethan
i forcefully took him and rose with us
but the vehicle they were riding in was
attacked
when i got to the wreck ethan and rose
were gone
the last time i was able to contact
ethan
i heard miranda's voice
she murdered him and she is not
gonna get away with it we do
what do we play as chris now
god damn it when does it end
what's that sir the mission
all of it three years trying to put this
thing in the ground
three years too long
no go get her
so bsaa got here already they didn't
waste any time
mission adjustment no it doesn't change
anything
terminate miranda and rescue
the mission what the [ __ ] failure's not
an option let's have some fun people
like old times move out roger
okay i don't like me
i want to know what the hell you're
saying find out what you can
roger that i'm alright
in a while since we fought together i
mean i didn't see this coming
at last the desert doing nothing but
recon's gotten me out of shape
but thanks to your recon we know
miranda's plan couldn't quite believe it
when i heard you turn yourself in the
mia though
taking five shots to the head's nothing
to sneeze at either
spooky i mean a lot of them
were able to take five shots of the head
so
damn look at that big tree
the alpha
they've gone too far
christ the tree's like pretty rough down
there
how are you planning on reaching the
objective first we're gonna have to take
that thing out
i've got your back boss let's get to
work
everyone watch for hostile bio weapons
roger
oh my god
a dragoon
what is that a target locator
huh
made contact with a group of hostile bio
weapons
my old gun
it's so weird because so much crap
happens to ethan
you just kind of get desensitized to
like anything you're like
he is invincible and then he gets his
heart taken care of you're like
i don't
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this
[Music]
what the hell is that thing it's all
new to my seat that's probably where
miranda is
let's go
oh [ __ ] jesus what the hell
it's uh moving very oddly large mutated
fire weapons
thank you
can i get through the house
i miss explosives
i need to back up
he set himself on fire somehow
whoa whoa whoa
i've never heard of a mutant icy colony
growing so huge
turn around turn around
i wish there's a quick turn button it
would make this game so much easier
supposed to be easy it's only my power
oh that's like so many of them
uh
hit the fire guys
that's pretty dappy
hey
i'm glad they give you time to breathe
jesus how many of these [ __ ]
dudes do i have to bloody oh i have
these
wow oh wait
they are smart i will give them that
they they duck out the way they know
when to die
oh [ __ ] sake come on
oh
[Applause]
yeah i mean yeah
i probably
why can you stop now
i've reached the target location chase
damn this is big
all right lobo marking the target roger
that boss
wait what
i'm all set here show me where to shoot
that captain
can you give me a target here um
looking around
whoa
okay
hold rt to mark the target so
anywhere around here ready
what was it what is the target
i just gotta hold it
[Applause]
go
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
okay i'm just dealing with some [ __ ]
[Applause]
there here be something stimulating
oh [ __ ] ballsacks
where are they guys you're right
captain they must be after
is the target locator working how many
are there
yeah okay they're coming from the mold
oh
i'm sure they're thinking the same about
you
it takes a minute to target the point
try and keep the laser on it as long as
you can numbers are increasing
oh [ __ ] here they come
oh they're big boys they're big boys
oh [ __ ] back myself up into a corner
this is a bad idea
i thought the house is back up here oh
my god
okay good man good man all right
no not into another corner that's
another bad idea
oh hell but
okay what have i got
oh i got flash for me
oh baby
come on pull the pin
[Applause]
oh my god
that's single
um
okay
take that good mega mice must be below
i'm on my way
thanks for following dadman that master
pair
interested me
i found a way down i'm going in the rest
of you stay back
i compared the mold at the village with
a sample from the bakers and
there's no sign of the genome editing we
saw in the e-series
the stuff originated here oh
so the stuff that evelyn had came from
here
and then what was that the people who
were selling it to the brother
they called like the connections or
something
i don't know something like that wasn't
it
because it wasn't actually umbrella that
made it it was a different
group
they weren't selling it to the brother
brother was going to sell it off
to other people what was he called again
that crazy baker brother
okay i guess
i guess like i do have uh grenades which
is nice
i also have a combat knife
but oh my god i'll be using that
oh
no [ __ ] off
i got a tough guy here i'm gonna need
backup
hello
come on
just
hold up
oh boy
yes
i'll keep going the rest of you stay
above ground
chris is a boss
[Music]
they can take so many hits
so if miranda was the fake mia where's
the real one i doubt she saw any further
use for her
yeah i don't get any of this how did
miranda even know rose exists
the moldy little bird told her maybe we
can figure that out later
focus on the plan so yeah i guess
they figure that miranda killed her but
that's not
necessarily what happened
i found it it's the mega my seat
it's a [ __ ] massive baba
what what
oh my gosh
can i make things oh my god i haven't
picked anything up
oh okay
out for the squad i've located the mega
my seat
so now we can end this mess after all
about damn time so is that bros
and two explosives aren't there's enough
there to blow the whole village sky high
let's get out of here and blow the damn
place
not before i end miranda i'm not taking
any more chances
i'm going in
captain i have eyes on miranda at the
ceremony site
keep your distance do not move until i
give the order
i know it's too late now but we really
should have told ethan the plan
there wasn't time you think we didn't
expect miranda to act so soon
even so you should have told him
yes yeah i agree
and now ethan's dead and he survived so
much and he all he was trying to do was
get his little rose and if this is rose
i don't think he would have gone through
so much
to see this giant mutant
baby
see it's facial features and everything
god that thing is gonna need one massive
diaper
this must be miranda's lab oh cool
oh i love stuff like this okay let's
let's take a
take a good look
okay so if the mold variant
whatever the hell it's called
originated from here then somehow the
connections or whatever they're called
put that into a little girl or did they
just create
evelyn with it i don't know what
happened send her off on a boat
oh maybe this will just tell us
everything
oh it's the the crests
uh salvatore moreau cadeau affinity
low brain functions surprisingly low
the cadeau has caused drastic changes to
internal organs transforming them into
organs similar to fish like gills and a
swim bladder
another subject with irregular cell
division causing him to transform into a
giant fish
the subject is unable to control this
transformation too many defects an
unfil unfit vessel for eva
eva evelyn
just trying to make another one
alcina de metresque uh most
favorable so she probably was the
favorite uh brain functions normal
regeneration rate is incredibly fast the
subject can heal
an external wound within seconds and
grow her nails into claws in mere
moments
rapid regeneration also means an
increased body size
note due to a hereditary blood disease
the subject
most must ingest human flesh and blood
on a regular basis to maintain
regeneration properties
i suspect that if the subject's
regeneration is not properly balanced
then she may mutate uncontrollably
which she did an unfit vessel for eva
carl heisenberg incredibly favorable oh
so
actually he was the favorite um has
electric organs similar to the electric
ray
narc japonica these electric organs are
connected to the subject's nervous
system
can therefore pass and control
electricity through the entire body
allowing control of magnetic fields
which use which is used to move
metal splendid specimen but still an
unfit vessel for eva yeah so she was
just trying to make another evelyn it
seems like
and now she's got rose which is the
perfect one
[Music]
um donna benaviento the most
terrifying boss of this game jeez
honestly it was i was so good it was so
good anyway
um favorable brain functions normal
although
severe mental illness physically
she is no different from a regular human
however she can secrete a signal
producing
substance which controls plants infected
by the mutants
muta my seed when humans absorb the
pollen from a particular flower she can
cause him to have hallucinations ah
makes sense however she is mentally
underdeveloped and has divided her cadet
amongst her
dolls in order to control them from a
distance an unfilled vessel
for evil
so they're using this to control the bio
weapons
guess i
she's a witch confirmed
who do we think these are the
townspeople
dear miranda my deepest apologies for
not meeting you in person i would love
nothing more than to visit your quaint
village once more however i'm incredibly
incredibly busy then again i suppose for
an immortal woman such as yourself you
no longer remember this poor half-dead
medical student in the snow
i've always cherished the revelations i
came to 15 years ago when i stayed in
your village
i was inspired by your research to think
one could transform a human by infecting
them with an organism
positively visionary i knew that with
the knowledge
i could achieve my own vision for the
next step in human evolution
even after two world wars and humanity
on the cusp of another
my conviction never wavered i realized
however
through the many nights of intellectual
talks you and i shared
that your conviction differed from mine
you hope to bring back a single dead
person
oh well i aim to change the world
your experiments on the mold did not
have would not evaded me in my endeavor
to achieve an exponential
infection i thought a virus would be
more effective
that is why my dear i had to leave you i
still regret never telling you goodbye
my apologies for reminiscing i actually
have news that i
thought might please you i found the key
to evolution
the prague frogit progenitor
a virus found in africa
i plan to start a company with friends
and colleagues dedicated the viruses
research
i will call it umbrella just like the
symbol in the cave that we spoke about
the symbol in the cave i am one step
closer
to making my vision of reality i hope
you'll be able to achieve your goals in
day two
you taught me so much and for that i'll
be forever in your debt
your lifelong student oswell spencer
damn so she oh my gosh this is
the this is the
the the beginning of like everything
it's her but where does she come from
what's her story i mean she's
strange i can't die no way
but she taught him everything about the
mold
and then he started everything in africa
damn
the creepy eye
who's that is that her her and her baby
so did something happen to her i don't
know something was i'm trying to figure
out of it
so she obviously got turned immortal
somehow and uh she's a scientist so she
did research so she found out about this
mold i guess maybe the maltoderm
also but then killed her baby or
something i don't know she's trying to
get her baby back and that's all she
cares about
oh her baby didn't die as a baby then
she grew
wait that's not evelyn is that evelyn
it could be evelyn
do we think that's evelyn guys do we
think her daughter was
evelyn that we knew from rezzy7
why was she sent away in a boat though
how did that happen
because all evelyn wanted was a family
emily it looks like her
no there's nothing written on the back
of the photos
my eva it's been 100 years since i lost
you to the spanish flu
i was so powerless back then but now
now i can bring you back to light from
the mega mist seat
i had to test your new vessel's
regenerative abilities
i took her apart and revived her in the
mega missous
regulator the giant's chalice all that's
left is to merge her with the meg in my
seat
the ceremony can begin after i lost you
i was so stricken with grief that i
wandered into a cave to die
i so wanted to be with you again and
that's when i found it
then mega my seat completely by accident
when i touched the black substance my
mind was overcome with knowledge
the mega myself breaks down and absorbs
the consciousness of those who have
perished
i knew that if your consciousness was in
there too then there would be a way to
bring you back
okay i just needed the right vessel
when i returned to the village i
implanted the villagers with mold from
the megamises
that way i can control them and
experiment on them i have experimented
on hundreds of people just to find you
the perfect vessel
i even tried to increase the efficiency
of finding a vessel by
creating a parasite i call kadeau yet
none of my experiments came to fruition
there were some like alcena who were
close to being perfect
but most turned into lichens
i was once approached by an organization
who said they would assist me i gave
them some of the molds and your d
okay again some of the molds and your
dna that's why she looks like her
but all they created was another defect
evelyn
boom got it but that's why evelyn looks
like
her child because it's got her dna so
that makes sense
why did she do that though oh right
because they said they would assist her
i guess then again not a complete
failure
i learned of rose thanks to them and i
knew she would be the perfect person
why why i i don't know
why why would that be
there was some interference but i was
able to
verify her suitability
tell me why now my research is finally
complete
eva i've waited too long to see you
again
hey we've have we seen this picture
before
yeah wasn't this picture in rezzy seven
i don't know no
yeah it probably was if she was working
with them
oh that's cool it's it's all coming it's
all coming together
that's pretty cool i still don't 100
understand why
rose is the perfect vessel when everyone
wasn't and even
evelyn wasn't perfect because evelyn
seemed pretty perfect to me although the
brother did
get out of her control somehow i'm not
quite sure how he managed to do that so
she didn't have full control over
everyone
so many pictures of her and her baby
show me your hands um bryce this is
alpha where is miranda right now oh
is that actually mia it's still the
ceremony
whatever she's doing she's staying but
god damn it really is you
i'm glad you saved me why are you here
i was caught in houston experiments
wait did you say mia mia winters in the
flesh
what's the situation up there
don't get distracted stick to the
mission i'm headed to the ceremony site
wait you can't leave me here
you promised damn it you said that you
would keep us safe
we did everything that you asked we
moved over here everything
and i didn't care so long as we were
together
so you tell me where is my husband
where is my daughter well your husband
he's gone had his heart ripped out
i couldn't save him but i can save rose
come on it's not safe here after all
what do you mean he's gone
he's dead
i'm sorry mia but we have to leave
we have to destroy this village no
you're wrong
i tried to keep this a secret but
you don't understand how special he is
ethan are you still alive
no easter
oh my god
someone is there
no freaking way dude
ethan's a vampire he doesn't even need a
heart
he's the real vampire of the game screw
lady dimitris
did i get here
god freezes [ __ ]
my body
[Music]
how
no i still have to save bros
wrong it wasn't miranda
you were always dead what
what are you saying i can still
see miranda didn't kill you
[Music]
you mean you didn't think it was weird
no matter how much you got hurt i did
think it was weird i called it out
multiple times
three years ago the baker house
you were murdered by jack
yeah and then i had the mold in me three
years ago
that's it no way
you shouldn't even be able to walk
around
[Music]
quit messing with my head
you shouldn't be walking
screw you so she's kept him alive this
whole time
with her mother what else
i i did all that
hi
your whole body is nothing but mold
you can't ever see your family again
[Music]
family
my daughter you're already dead
i will save
rose
well i'm glad they actually uh explained
his
crazy just
body horror good stuff that did not faze
him
but mia definitely has the mold on her
last he awakes
oh hello where am i my carriage ethan
you were having a nightmare
duke your battle with heisenberg was a
sight to see
but to think miranda would show herself
long have i been out not long till dawg
duke i need a favor
take me to miranda i assumed as much and
i'm already on the way
i'm going to arrive shortly i can't wait
to find out more about his backstory
but ethan are you sure of this your body
is
well falling apart yeah
i noticed ah yes
foolish help me to ass
speaking of foolish questions who or
what are you
even i can't quite answer that
we're here
i owe you one mr winters i'm afraid you
can't return to your old world any
longer
are you ready
yeah i have to be
your old world
i gotta go
ah so i guess if you didn't choose uh
mia in the last game then you didn't get
the canon ending because it doesn't
really make sense if you didn't choose
mia but
so i guess yeah i saw victor light is
right mia got
i i chose anyway to save mia
to back vaccinate her to make her better
to cure her
and then i guess ethan didn't so
that's why rose is wanted because she's
ethan's baby but how did mother
in all her glory not notice this
preparation is more important now than
ever before
i agree
good i somehow have chris's
crystal oh yeah your cigar you will want
this one
oh the assemblage of life and machine
i can feel lord heisenberg's essence
through it
okay i should be good to go now this
will be my
last time watching you walk away
do you feel sad about it
okay game is saved
please do not restart
thank you
hope everyone went to the lou and how to
smash and now you're back
oh damn ethan actually is falling apart
i can't run
oh i need to rearrange
so you should be down here yeah yeah
can i oh geez
oh geez
i might actually put that there
look at my new guns and your guns are so
shiny
and stupid super new cause i am going on
an adventure
get out of ethan's way you can't do this
yes baby
beautiful gun
[Music]
the branches are tickling me
my beautiful daughter
come to me
is that you oh
how i've missed you
what what
my power is leaving me is it going into
rose
miranda
interesting your body certainly is
normal give rose to me
now you will see once i kill you
properly
oh
and you try to take it away from me
i will take what is due
my desires will be fulfilled
rose is mine
what the [ __ ]
you fulfilled your purpose
you disposed of my false children and
awakened the glorious mega mice
now please do not worry the little rose
i assure you i'll uh
[Music]
how about this
ugh
please mr winters
i shall finish
don't know what i'm seeing here
everything is
so bright and dark at the same time
here i cut
oh jesus i'll take wonderful
okay okay okay
how can you deny
i don't have any of my cool ass blaze
i only have one health left that's my
head that's not good
once you realize rose is my goddamn kick
yeah your [ __ ] eggs
oh god
the men of my seat saved me from the
pits of despair
it granted me this splendid power
yeah right all it's done is drive nuts
[Music]
yeah i agree
hold still you hold still
whoa i don't even know where she's gone
most of the time
you'll kill me yeah you probably would
i'm not
i'm out of uh there's nothing to pick up
either
i can take any form i desire yeah i know
even your lovely wife i know i've seen
it after all
everyone dies
[Applause]
whoa
now mr winters i think it's time you
left things in mind
[ __ ] jesus not again the hell i will
die
it's fine i'll do this again
okay let's try this again
my beautiful daughter
come to me
is that you oh
how you fulfilled your purpose
mr winters you disposed of my
false children and awakened the glorious
megalith
okay while she's talking let's pop that
let's pop
down some mans then do not worry
about rose but i assure you i'll provide
her with
trees i can't believe something
no health to pick up the house
here i come yep
come on
[Music]
did she just
i shall put you to rest
um no [ __ ] no [ __ ]
this
what [ __ ]
can you please trip on one of my minds
that'd be very nice
oh he did thank you see
all it's done is drag you nuts
[Music]
after all everyone dies
oh no
oh god okay
[Laughter]
oh this is why i died last time i'm not
very good at this
now mr winters i think it's time you
left things in mind okay
oh scary scary scary scary
combined rose with a mega mice [ __ ]
horror
please restore your health
i can take any form i desire
oh [ __ ] off even your mother
i know i saw it
no because i'll just keep pressing
restart
right
how am i supposed to okay quick ethan
quick quick get it get it ethan get it
eat this
get it
oh god oh gosh
oh god she doesn't even know she doesn't
care
[Laughter]
i will take my daughter
no you [ __ ]
i shall finish this i'm scared
hell where's my years of loneliness
ever think the problem might be you
miranda you're not capable of real love
oh for [ __ ] sakes oh god
[Music]
i think it's the same about you i'm
shooting you so many times i'm running
out of ammo now
of course
ensure i never see your face
hit her in the eyes go on ethan you can
do this
my daughter
[Music]
uh oh jesus
rose you really are special how did you
survive that
it's all right and you're so clean how
oh no
[Music]
oh ethan
ethan come on ethan
come on ethan wake up
oh no chris ethan
he did it it's finished i think we've
finished each other
ethan we got a move
oh chris get us to safety
keep moving ethan there's a bum in that
thing that'll hold this whole village
sky high
hey look at me when i hit this trigger
we can't be anywhere near it
ah damn it me is waiting for you
she's alive you hear me alive
oh man i'm so sorry
i love you keep rose safe hey
is he really dying this time tell
yourself
now come on it's not that much further
watch over teach her to be strong
goodbye rosemary
ethan
oh he gave her a little jacket
oh he's gonna place the bum in the heart
okay good the big baby wasn't broke
that's good
i think ethan's gonna die no matter what
he does
so this is probably a good shot
i mean he already is dead though isn't
he technically
go go take us up now
isn't she gonna ask about ethan oh i
guess she thinks he's dead no
wait she knows where are you
get moving we have to get clear no we
can't
go not without my husband mia sit down
and strap in
not before you tell me where ethan is
i know he wouldn't abandon us
well he did tell me what's going on
where
what was that i told you to sit down
where is he
chris what have you done
he's gone i tried
he stayed so we could all escape
i'm sorry
captain you need to see this
yeah she did bsaa didn't send
soldiers this is a bio weapon
what the hell were they thinking
orders captain pick up the rest of the
squad
plot a course for bsa europe hq
someone's got to pay
[Music]
no
[Music]
this is such a cool animation i love
[Music]
this
[Music]
this is cool
[Music]
through
in his hands
i'm definitely going to listen to this
[Music]
films they might seem like kubo and two
strings and stuff
and i cry
[Music]
in turn is due in a blink the girl was
trapped inside a mirror
her parents though had searched all day
and at last
arrived with rampant rage father fought
the witch
while mother's loving touch shattered
the dark enchantment
but the witch was strong and father
yelled save our daughter
so mother bore their child to safety as
the forest was consumed
even now the burnt forest is a grim
reminder
of father's sacrifice to this day
any child who stares too long into the
charred wasteland
will be haunted by nightmares of getting
lost
while picking berries
[Music]
she changed the ending of the story that
was a really nice way to wrap it up as
well
[Music]
like returning to the bedtime story
so cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
though
packages
[Music]
[ __ ] jesus christ i am scared of you
i'm scared of you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
do you think the little boy will be able
to touch the moon
nobody can touch the moon is too far
away wait what if he has a rocket ship
uh okay then you can touch it but it'd
be very very
cold
you were being silly i don't think the
moon
oh
hey dad happy birthday
sorry i missed last week i have a lot of
tests coming up
you know how it is
[Music]
talk to the goddamn devil
duty calls
i love you
yeah i found her she got gray hair like
a daddy where else
today of all days
we have a situation you're needed
evelyn evelyn don't you ever
call me that again oh oh it's just a
joke gross
funny i can show you things even chris
doesn't know i can do
we have a clear
i can handle it she's just a kid
i want you to keep it together rose
you're a lot like him you know
i know
is that chris
the father story is now done we get to
play as rose
yeah oh
that's cool
oh okay okay i'm happy now i was like no
is this the end of resident evil's kind
of standalone games
oh yes
hell yeah i'm all for playing as rose
and she seems like a badass oh
so excited as always have a lovely day
or evening
and bye
you